สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ 201
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
เสาร์
เมื่อวันนี้วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
:00 นกี่นาที
8 นาทีค่ะ
ตอนนี้เป็นเวลากลางคืนใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่ออสเตรเลียตอนนี้
กลางคืนไหมคะ
ที่บ้านตอนนี้
4 ทุ่ม 8 นาทีก็กลางคืนเหมือนกันใช่ไหม
อ้าวแล้วทำไมครูฟ้าไม่นอนล่ะคะ 4 ทุ่ม
แล้วนะคะครูฟ้า
ต้องทำงานไงคะนักเรียน
อ๋อผู้หญิงบอกว่าฮัลโหลครูฟ้าห้ามนอน
ก็เลยนอนไม่ได้นะคะ
น่าสงสารเขานะคะนักเรียนก็ตอนนี้ 4 ทุ่ม
ใช่ไหมคะที่ไทยที่ไทยเนี่ยยังไม่ 4 ทุ่ม
แต่ว่าผู้หญิงและครูฟ้าเราก็อยู่ตอนกลาง
คืนเหมือนกันครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบตอนกลาง
คืนไหม
ครูฝ้ายชอบตอนกลางคืนมาก
ทำไมคะทำไมครูฟ้าชอบตอนกลางคืนน่ะตอนกลาง
คืนนี่มันมืดนะมันมืดแบบ
เป็นสีดำใช่ไหม
มันมืดๆๆๆๆๆๆๆเป็นสีดำ
ก็ใช่แหละค่ะมันมืด
มืด
ครูฟ้าถึงชอบตอนกลางคืน
เพราะว่าครูฟ้า
ชอบ
ชอบอะไร
นักเรียนนักเรียนรอฟังอยู่
ชอบ
ชอบอะไรนะไม่ได้ยิน
ผี
อ๋อครูฟ้าชอบครูฟ้า
ชอบผีไง
นี่ค่ะนักเรียนเราบอกว่าเวลาตอนกลางคืนก็
จะมีผี
อันนี้ผีฝรั่งไหม
มันไม่ใช่ผีไทย
เป็นแบบนี้
น่ากลัวมากนะคะนักเรียนถ้าใครไม่รู้จักผี
ไทย Search  Google ก็ได้นะคะ Thai  Ghost
นะคะ
นักเรียนบอกว่านึกว่าจะให้นักเรียนพิมพ์
ว่าผีไทยทำไมผู้หญิงไม่เสิร์ช Google
อุ๊ยแล้วผู้หญิงจะนอนได้ไหมคะนักเรียน
นักเรียนคะผีไทยที่น่ากลัวที่สุดก็น่าจะ
แบบนี้นะ
มีเยอะมากๆใช่
ครูฟ้าชอบครูฟ้าชอบตอนกลางคืน
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าชอบผี
ผู้ฟัง
ก็
ตอนที่ครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมตอนที่
ฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
เห็นใช่ไหมหรือว่าฟังฟังเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
ผีเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็จะแบบไม่เอาไม่เอานอนไม่
ได้กลัวกลัวแต่ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะอยู่
เอ่อ
[เพลง]
ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยไม่มีผี
ไม่รู้สิ
แต่
ไม่กลัวไง
คืออยู่ได้ถ้าแบบว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีห้องนอน
ใช่ไหมห้องนอนของครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
นักเรียนประมาณนี้แหละนะนอนคนเดียวที่
ออสเตรเลียก็ไม่กลัวผีโอเคโอเค
[เพลง]
อยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี 2 ชั้นไหมหรือว่า
บ้านครูฟ้าเป็นบ้านชั้นเดียว a หรือ B
บ้านครูฟ้า
เป็นบ้าน
ชั้นเดียวค่ะ
เป็นบ้านชั้นเดียวใช่ไหมแล้วครูฟ้าเข้าไป
ในบ้านครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าบ้านครูฟ้าอยู่
เนี่ยเขาอายุกี่ปีแล้ว
you  canva เนี่ยนะคะออสเตรเลียเนี่ยมัน
ไม่ถึง 100 ปีด้วยมั้ง
มันใหม่มากนะ
จะ 10 ปี 10 ปี 20 ปี
อายุ
100 ปี
[เพลง]
เราจะกลัวไหม
กลัวสิคะผู้หญิงยิ่งเก่ายิ่งน่ากลัวนะคะ
นักเรียน
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยก็เหมือนกันนะ
อยู่บ้านที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเวลาอยู่ที่
บ้านบ้านที่เราไม่เคยอยู่ใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
202220  21 ครูไฟล์อยู่บ้านที่พัทยาใช่
ไหมครูฟ้าอยู่ตั้งแต่เด็กอยู่มานานแล้ว
โอเคแต่พอครูฟ้า
ไปอยู่ออสเตรเลียใช่ไหมเป็นบ้านใหม่ครู
ฟ้าไม่เคยอยู่
บางครั้งเนี่ยใช่เราก็อาจจะคิด
บ้านหลังนี้เนี่ย
มีผีหรือเปล่า
ผีแต่ครูฟ้าก็ชอบผีมาก
ก็แปลกใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนกลัวผีแต่ก็ชอบผี
อ่ะถ้าอย่างนั้นเนี่ยวีดีโอนี้เราก็เลยมา
คุยกันเรื่องผีที่อยู่ในบ้าน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
หรือว่าอาจจะเป็นความคิดความคิดของครูฟ้า
แล้วกันครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่ไหนที่ไหนในบ้าน
ที่จะมีผีอยู่
มีผีเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียน
ที่นี่ไหมนักเรียนอาจจะมีห้องตรงนี้ก็ได้
ใช่ไหมมีเตียงนอน
อย่างนี้อันนี้ก็อาจจะมีผีอยู่ที่ห้องใต้
หลังคา
ในห้องนี้ก็อาจจะมีผี
หรือเปล่าครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่บ้านเนี่ยตรงไหน
ในบ้านที่จะมีผี
ให้ครูฟ้าคิด
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ที่ไหนคะ
ที่แบบว่าที่นี่แหละ
100% เลย
มีผีแน่นอน
ผู้หญิงคิดว่านะ
ครูฟ้าคิดก่อน
เตียงนอนแต่ผีเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ที่เตียงนอน
นะคะนักเรียนเตียงนอนบางที่เนี่ยมันจะมี
เสาใช่ไหมเสาของเตียง
อย่างนี้
[เพลง]
แล้วมันจะมีตรงนี้แหละค่ะใต้เตียงผู้หญิง
คิดว่าใต้เตียงเนี่ยน่าจะมีผีอยู่ถ้าเรา
นอนอยู่บนเตียงใช่ไหมเราอาจจะได้ยินเสียง
มีอะไร
มีอะไรอยู่ใต้เตียงเราก็จะคิด
อี๋มีผีอยู่ใต้เตียงหรือเปล่าผู้หญิงก็
เลยคิดว่าที่ที่หนึ่งที่น่าจะมีผีในบ้าน
เนี่ยน่าจะเป็นใต้เตียงเตียงนอนที่ห้อง
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีใต้เตียงไหมคะ
มีใต้เตียงค่ะคุณหญิง
แต่ว่า
แต่ว่าเตียงมันไม่มีที่แล้ว
เพราะว่ามันมีกรองมันมีกล่องเพียบเลยนะคะ
เพราะว่ามีของเยอะ
อาจจะผีอาจจะอยู่ในกล่องใต้เตียงก็ได้นะ
ถ้าจะเหนื่อยขนาด
มันจะเหนื่อยนะคะ
คิดว่าที่บ้านเนี่ยมีที่ไหนอีกที่คนไทย
เนี่ยจะคิดว่าตรงนี้ต้องมีผีแน่ๆเลย
ฟ้าคิดว่าที่นี่ที่ไหนคะครูฟ้า
อยู่ใกล้ๆกันค่ะ
อยู่ใกล้ๆกับเตียงนอนหรอคะ
ตู้เสื้อผ้า
ข้างในนี้เนี่ยข้างในก็จะมีเสื้อใช่ไหม
เราจะมีเสื้อ
มี
กระโปรงมีกางเกงใช่ไหมตู้เสื้อผ้าเออใช่
เนาะเวลาที่คนไทยดูทีวีดูทีวีนะคะนัก
เรียนแล้วก็ทีวีเกี่ยวกับผีเนี่ย
ในตู้เสื้อผ้าเนี่ยจะมีผีเวลาที่เราเปิด
ใช่ไหม
เราจะแบบใจออกมา
ใช่แล้วค่ะ
น่ากลัวนะคะ
แล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่ไหนอีกที่มีผีผู้หญิง
คิดว่าอ่ะผู้หญิงก่อนคุยก่อนให้เวลาครู
ฟ้าคิดผู้หญิงคิดว่าที่นี่ก็น่าจะมีผีนะ
คะ
ที่ไหน
แต่ว่าบ้านครูฟ้าน่าจะไม่มีเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นบ้านชั้นเดียวแต่ถ้าเราเนี่ย
เป็นบ้าน 2 ชั้นใช่ไหมคะมีชั้น 1 แล้วก็
มีชั้น 2 เนี่ยเวลาที่เรารู้ฟ้าอยู่ชั้น 1
แล้วคิดจะขึ้นชั้น 2 มันก็ต้องมีบันไดใช่
ไหมบันได
ครูหญิงคิดว่าที่บันไดเนี่ยแหละค่ะจะมีผี
ผีเนี่ยอาจจะไม่ได้อยู่แต่เราเนี่ยจะได้
ยินเสียง
เดินตรงบันไดไงถ้าเป็นเวลากลางคืนทุกคน
ทุกคนทุกคนที่อยู่ในบ้านเนี่ยนอนแล้วอาจ
จะซักเที่ยงคืน
ปีหนึ่งอย่างนี้ค่ะตี 1
เราอาจจะได้ยินเสียง
เสียงเท้าใช่ไหมมีเสียงเหมือนคนเนี่ยเดิน
ตรงบันไดเนี่ยมีผีค่ะผู้หญิงคิดว่านะที่
บ้านครูฟ้าคิดว่ามีที่ไหนอีกที่บ้านที่
น่าจะมีผี
[เพลง]
ครูฝ้ายคิดว่า
พี่ฟ้าคิดว่า
อะไรคะครูฟ้าที่ครูฟ้ากำลังวาดอยู่
กระจกค่ะ
[เพลง]
กระจกแบบใน
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่กระจกเนี่ย
เวลาเอาไว้ดูใช่ไหมดูสองหน้าเวลาเราแต่ง
หน้าทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่กระจกอ่ะมีผีนะคะ
เพราะว่าผีในชอบอยู่ในกระจกใช่ไหม
เวลาที่เราส่งกระจกอ่ะหรอ
ในห้องครูฟ้ามีกระจกไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะ
ไม่มีใช่ๆเวลาที่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไปนอนโรงแรมใช่ไหมคะโรงแรมอาจจะมีหนึ่ง
ดาวสองดาว 3 ดาว 4 ดาว 5 ดาวเนี่ยเวลานอน
โรงแรมไม่ชอบโรงแรมที่แบบมี
เตียงนอนอย่างนี้
มีเตียงนอนตรงนี้ใช่ไหมแล้วตรงนี้
ปลายเตียงเป็นกระจกเวลาที่เรานอนเราก็จะ
เห็นตัวเองในกระจกอ่ะไม่ชอบเลยอ่ะค่ะแบบ
สมมุติถ้าแบบเราจะตี 2 อย่างนี้เราตื่นมา
เดินๆๆจะไปห้องน้ำใช่ไหมมันก็จะเห็นกระจก
ก่อนน่ะมันรู้สึกแบบน่ากลัวมากเลยนะน่า
กลัวจริงๆค่ะน่ากลัวจริงๆ
ตายๆๆไม่ชอบนะคะไม่ชอบเห็นกระจก
น่ากลัวค่ะ
ครูฟ้าเขาชอบเรื่องผีไงเขาก็คิดได้นะคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีอีกที่นึงแล้วกัน
วาดไปแล้วด้วยอ่ะแต่ที่นี่มี
หรออันนี้มีคนแบบ
คิดว่าอาจจะมีก็ได้นะเพราะว่าอาจจะอ่านมา
จากการ์ตูนหรือเปล่านะคะก็คือห้องน้ำค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
ห้องน้ำผู้หญิง
ครูฟ้ามันอาจจะไม่ใช่เออเนาะแต่ห้องน้ำ
ที่บ้านของเราหรอจะมีผีแต่เวลาคนไทยเด็กๆ
อ่ะค่ะแบบอายุสัก 6 ขวบถึงอายุ 12 อย่าง
นี้แล้วเราไปโรงเรียนเรียนหนังสือใช่ไหม
คะบางครั้งคุณครูก็ชอบบอกว่าห้องน้ำเนี่ย
มีผีนะเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นบ้านคนไทยเนี่ยอัน
นี้เป็นบ้านใช่ไหม
แต่ห้องน้ำเนี่ยจะอยู่ข้างนอกบ้านไง
[เพลง]
บ้านคนไทยเนี่ย
อันนี้บ้านของเราอยู่ที่นี่ถ้าจะไปห้อง
น้ำเราต้องเดินใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นประตูบ้าน
เราต้องเปิดประตูแล้วก็ออกแล้วก็เดินๆๆๆ
ไปข้างหลังบ้าน
ก็จะเป็นห้องน้ำไงห้องน้ำมันก็จะไกลจาก
ที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะแล้วถ้าเป็นเวลากลางคืน
มันก็ดูน่ากลัวก็อาจจะมีผีก็ได้ไงบ้านคน
ไทยมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้เยอะๆก็เลยคิดว่าห้อง
น้ำนี่แหละน่าจะมีผี
มีที่ไหนอีกไหมคะในบ้านของเราอ่ะที่น่าจะ
มีผีอีก
ตอนกลางคืนน่ะ
เป็นกลางวันก็ได้นะถ้าผีชอบกลางวันนะคะ
ห้องไหนที่มีผีหรอคะหรือ
ไหนที่ไหนที่มีผี
อาจจะไม่ได้เป็นห้องก็ได้ไง
ใครอะไรคะเนี่ย
อะไรคะ
ห้องพระใช่ไหมแบบที่บ้านเนี่ยมันก็จะมี
ห้องใช่ไหมห้องห้องนอนห้องทำอาหารห้องดู
ทีวีแล้วก็จะมี 1 ห้องใช่ไหมบ้านครูฟ้ามี
ไหมอ่ะก็จะมีพระ
มีค่ะ
แล้วก็ตรงนี้ก็จะมีแจกันแล้วก็มีดอกไม้
ไหมคะห้องพระเพราะว่าเราเนี่ยศาสนาพุทธ
ใช่ไหมคะ budism ที่บ้านเราเนี่ยก็จะมี
ห้องพระแต่ครูฟ้า
อี๋ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
กลัวพระนะคะ
พระเนี่ยชนะผีแล้วทำไมในห้องพระถึงมีผี
ล่ะ
ก็เคยได้ยินไหมคะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าคนไทยเห็นไหว้พระใช่ไหมแล้วบอก
พระเนี่ยเป็นกอดใช่ไหมคะเหมือนก๊อด
แต่ถ้าห้องนั้นเนี่ย
คนไม่ไปไหว้ใช่ไหมคนมีห้องพระแต่ไม่ไหว้
พระพระก็บ๊ายบาย
แล้วนะแล้วผีก็เข้ามาในห้องพระ
แล้วเราก็จะรู้สึกกลัว
เพราะว่า
เพราะว่าห้องพระเราไม่เข้าใช่ไหมผีก็เลย
มาอยู่เงียบๆ
เออใช่ห้องพระก็มีผีนะคะเห็นไหมที่บ้านคน
ไทยเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนที่ไหนก็มีผีแล้วนัก
เรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนคิดว่าที่ไหนในบ้านที่
มีผีอีกไหมนอกจากที่เราบอกไว้ใช่ไหมมีใต้
เตียง
มีตู้เสื้อผ้าเนาะ
ห้องน้ำนะคะกระจกหรือว่าที่บันไดใช่ไหม
ที่เราบอกว่ามีผีแล้วนักเรียนคิดว่ามีที่
ไหนในบ้านอีกที่จะมีผีก็ comment บอกเรา
ได้นะคะจะวิดีโอนี้คุยกับครูฟ้าไปก่อน
เนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
นะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ